aquí tenemos una solución de sulfato de
cobre
el sulfato de cobre es un compuesto
iónico el cobre pierde dos electrones
así que el cobre tiene una carga dos más
y el sulfato tiene una carga dos menos
este es el camión y este es el avión
como pueden imaginar es fácil disolverlo
en un solvente polar como el agua así
que tenemos este compuesto en solución
acuosa lo hemos disuelto en agua y tiene
ese color azulado una manera de verlo es
que tenemos un montón de cationes de
cobre disueltos en agua y un montón de
aniones sulfato disueltos en agua
y ahora hagamos un pequeño experimento
pongamos un poco de zinc el zinc en
estado sólido es de color gris metálico
tomamos un poco de polvo metálico de
zinc y lo agregamos a la solución veamos
qué sucede aquí está el zinc en estado
sólido zinc
lo que ya teníamos en la solución que es
el sulfato de cobre que creen que pasará
los invito a que le pongan pausa al
vídeo y observen esta tabla de electro
negatividad es piensen en lo que ocurre
aquí en términos de electrones quien
quiere electrones qué es lo que pasará
bueno veamos las electro negatividades
aquí tenemos al cobre y al zinc y el
cobre es más electro negativo que el
zinc si hubiera alguna forma de que el
cobre le quite electrones al zinc lo
hará especialmente este cobre de la
derecha
esto es unión de cobre cargado
positivamente estos iones aman tomar
electrones para volverse neutrales y
miren ya algunos toman los electrones
entonces ocurre una reacción redox es
una reacción óxido reducción en donde el
cobre gana electrones que el zinc dona y
el cobre se convierte en un cobre sólido
y neutral mientras que el zinc metálico
se transforma en cationes de zinc aunque
en realidad tenemos un factor de zinc
disuelto en solución acuosa lo escribiré
sulfato de zinc
aquí tenemos 2 - y está en solución
acuosa que les parece dibujaré otro vaso
por aquí
así estaba antes de que la reacción
ocurriera pero después de la reacción
nos queda algo como esto el sulfato de
zinc es un líquido transparente y en
lugar de tener zinc que en el fondo
ahora tenemos cobre metálico el cobre ha
precipitado se ve algo así
para que me entiendan mejor escribamos
las reacciones parciales o también
llamadas semi reacciones primero
pensemos en la reacción parcial para el
zinc inicialmente teníamos al zinc en
estado sólido zinc sólido tiene un
estado de oxidación neutro es decir no
tiene carga y luego termina por acá con
una carga positiva 2 más y que fue lo
que pasó
bueno como perdió electrones entonces el
zinc es oxidado
oxidado
y qué le ocurrió al cobre bueno al
inicio el cobre es un camión en solución
acuosa y gana dos electrones entonces
termina con una carga neutral cobre en
estado sólido el cobre es reducido
reducido se vuelve más negativo podemos
decir que el cobre fue reducido por el
zinc y el zinc fue oxidado por el cobre
y observen que la carga del sulfato no
cambia así que cuando trabajen con un
compuesto iónico el estado de oxidación
será la carga ya no es una suposición